ce
ouah je ne sais pas pour vous mais moi
j'ai pris une claque
depuis ce matin à écouter toutes ces
personnages qui rentrent ces personnes
motivante
ces personnes debout derrière leurs
idées franchement j'ai pris beaucoup de
plaisir à les accompagner être avec eux
durant ces quelques semaines de
préparation et je voudrais juste qu'on
fasse au truc avant de commencer on leur
donne 10 secondes d'amour
supplémentaires et qu'on les
applaudissent encore
j'adore les idées j'adore les grandes
idées j'adore en avoir et depuis je suis
sorti de l'école d'ingénieurs ça fait
une petite dizaine d'années mon objectif
professionnel mon objectif personnel
c'est de faire émerger une grande idée
de la faire voir le jour de la faire
exister et j'ai eu beaucoup d'idées j'ai
eu des petites des moyennes des grandes
des idées qui sont pas allés très loin
d'autres qui sont allées encore moins
loin et puis une qui est allé un peu
plus loin grâce à l'aide d'une équipe
grâce à l'aide de partenaires grâce à
l'aide de gens de particuliers qui se
sont vraiment fédérer autour de cette
équipe
et voilà et je voudrais aujourd'hui ben
vous parler de cette fabrique des idées
de commencer pour détecter identifier
ces belles idées qui valent la peine
d'être poursuivi et qui valent la peine
d'être poussé plus loin jusqu'à là
jusqu'à existait un petit peu avant
l'école d'ingénieurs je pense que
j'étais au au lycée j'ai découvert le
monde des start-up le monde des start up
et j'ai découvert c'est elle en pleine
bulle internet dans les magazines à la
télé on en parlait on parlait de google
on parler de tous ces entrepreneurs qui
sans argent sans moyens montait des
empires montait surtout changer notre
façon notre façon de consommer notre
façon de voir les choses
notre façon de de produire les choses et
je me suis sentie proche de ces gens là
et à ce moment là j'ai su que la façon
dont j'allais faire pour pouvoir faire
émerger cette idée se prendrait la forme
d'une start up et puis un petit peu
avant ça et là je parle d'une époque que
les plus jeunes d'entre nous ne peuvent
pas connaître
une époque son téléphone portable une
époque sans internet
une époque sans facebook mais mouais ça
existait cette époque là
bah mon père à ramener à la maison le
premier ordinateur je devais avoir 10 11
ans et au bout de quelques jours
d'utilisation
au bout de quelques heures j'ai su que
la majorité des grandes idées du futur
passerait par là passerait par ce canal
là et je me suis consacré le bas le
reste de ma vie
j'aime les idées j'aime en avoir mais
j'aime aussi celle des autres et avant
de décliner justement ils ont rentré
dans cette fabrique des idées je
voudrais qu'on parle d'un postulat de
base est ce postulat gelé à qui il est
que la créativité
le fait d'avoir des idées est une
caractéristique uniformément répartie
dans l'humanité tout le monde peut avoir
des idées
tout le monde a le droit d'avoir des
idées tout le monde en a et ça j'en
étais persuadé en pratiquant les startup
weekend j'ai pas si vous connaissez mon
gros son concept son événement vous
arriver le vendredi avec une idée alors
vous pouvez être chercheur ingénieur ou
juste avoir vu de la lumière et avoir eu
envie de prendre un café
vous rentrez vous parlez de votre idée
vous réunissez des jeux autour de votre
idée et vous essayer de l'emmener le
plus loin possible durant le week-end et
à la fin du week end ce sont les idées
qui sont allés le plus loin qui sont
récompensés et des start-up week-end il
y en a partout sur la planète
il y en a un en amérique du sud y en a
en afrique y en a il y en a sur la bande
de gaza en palestine il y en en israël y
en a partout et à chaque fois je suis
allé dans énormément de startup weekend
et j'ai vu toutes ces personnes qui
avaient des idées et c'est là où je me
suis forgé cette conviction sur balles
heures la démocratisation des idées le
fait que tout le monde pouvait avoir des
idées et très tôt je me suis posé cette
question comment fait-on justement pour
qu'une idée ne restent pas qu'une idée
parce que la madame une fois que j'ai
parlé de tout et d'idées vous regardez
votre mari vous vous souvenez de sa
dernière bonne idée le distributeur de
rome amphibie qui vous permet de
décoller en toute situation
et là monsieur vous n'êtes pas en reste
parce que vous vous souvenez aussi de la
dernière bonne idée de madame un loupé
au beurre chocolat qui fait maigrir
on en reparlera aussi donc
donc voilà qu'est ce qui fait qu'une
idée reste reste dans sur le papier
reste une idée et qu'est ce qui fait
qu'une autre bain change notre façon de
vivre change notre société change notre
façon de consommer notre façon d'exister
et je me suis rendu compte qu'il y avait
un motif qu'il y avait un motif des
caractéristiques communes à toutes les
grandes idées qui voyait le jour qui
changer les choses et c'est ses
convictions ses motifs ces règles je les
ai acquises en expérimentant gelé a été
acquise en écoutant les autres
en regardant beaucoup de toc sur ted
beaucoup de gens pariaient sur ted en
regardant le petit peu tout ce qui se
faisait
et je vais vous devez lui que je vais
les partager avec vous ce soir il devait
commencer par une petite histoire pour
vous illustrer la première la première
de ses idées il était une fois un hiver
rude hiver parisien comme ce sont
souvent les hivers parisien et moins
jeunes consultants dans une institution
bancaire bien coller qui vient me voir
et me demandent aux bons plans au
pouvoir louer une voiture parce que tout
ce qu'ils trouvent
c'est trop cher c'est trop cher et n'en
trouve pas en plus elles sont très rares
il ya des ruptures de stock partout n'y
a pas de choix est séparé par tous et
vient me voir une fois deux fois trois
fois et continuer et franchement il est
vraiment comme comme un enfant qui
pleure et moi j'ai rien vraiment rien à
lui proposer jusqu'à ce que je lui fasse
un jour une boutade je lui fasse une
blague des attaques a loué la voiture de
ma mère elle est là elle sert à rien
elle prend la poussière dans le garage
ça lui ferait un peu d'argent et et toi
ben ça te permettra d'avoir une voiture
pour tes vacances
et là tu les regardes et il m'a regardé
on s'est regardé et
je me suis dit c'est peut-être pas si
con que ça et on a commencé à construire
avec mes associés avec une équipe
derrière avec des partenaires mason
modèle de location de voitures entre
particuliers pour le tourisme qui permet
de mettre en relation des voyageurs qui
cherche une voiture pour pour leurs
vacances et des particuliers qui ont une
voiture qui est disponible et donc la
règle qu'on peut sortir de ça c'est que
bah il faut utiliser votre maman de
manière éhontée dans votre business
non pour de vrai la règle c'est que vous
devez une grande idée répond un problème
une grande idée répond à une douleur une
grande idée répond à une souffrance
il faut que la personne en face de vous
souffre pleurs devant vous et que vous
puissiez vous avez vous et vous puissiez
avoir la capacité de lui apporter une
solution
et une fois que j'ai dit ça vous me
regarde en disant c'est à l'air assez
banal à ces mêmes vulgaire ce qu il en
train de nous dire mais regarder un
petit peu autour de vous notre économie
martiniquaise la plupart de notre
économie n'est pas basé sur une économie
de solutions elle est basée sur une
économie d'aubaine elle est basée sur
une économie de niches fiscales
d'incitation fiscale deux hommes de löw
et d'hommes de loi de loi de loi de
finances et ces idées là même si elles
peuvent vous faire gagner de l'argent
même si elles peuvent payer vos salaires
ne sont pas destinés à être des grandes
idées ne peuvent pas s'exporter ne
peuvent pas perdurer dans le temps elles
ont une date de péremption la date de
péremption de la loi la date de
péremption de la niche fiscale la date
de péremption des envies des touristes
de venir dans des hôtels ou d'aller
plutôt dans des gîtes et voilà donc il
faut vraiment base est une grande idée
se base sur un problème
la deuxième règle la deuxième grande
idée la deuxième caractéristique des
grandes idées c'est que une grande idée
n'a pas besoin d'argent pour émerger et
entendons nous bien une entreprise a
besoin d'argent qu'on se développer une
entreprise a besoin d'argent pour payer
des salaires pour avoir des locaux pour
pouvoir faire du marketing aller sur de
nouveaux territoires
mais pour pour voir émerger une grande
idée n'a pas besoin de sous et là encore
regardez autour de vous
combien de personnes qui veulent être
entrepreneurs qui veulent qu'ils ont
cette grande idée et qui vous disent ben
j attends la subvention de la région
j'attends le prêt bancaire au départ
lorsqu'on a commencé bas cette idée de
location de voitures entre particuliers
on a commencé avec 100 euros de capital
on n'avait pas de sous on a trouvé on a
cherché les moyens de pouvoir valider
notre idée sans argent on a montré on
appris au formulaire gratuit sur
internet pour permettre aux gens d'astra
leur voiture et un autre où leur
permettre de rechercher une voiture et
c'est parce qu'on a pu montrer qu'il ya
des gens qui étaient intéressés par ce
qu'on a pu montrer qu'il ya des gens
qu'ils voulaient ce service qui était
prêt parce qu'il souffrait et qu'ils
étaient prêts à acheter notre solution
que derrière des gens nous ont suivis
que derrière bas la banque nous a suivis
que derrière la région nous a suivis que
derrière tout l'écosystème nous a suivis
que des équipes nous ont rejoints que
nos associés nous ont rejoints que des
investisseurs nous ont rejoint derrière
c'est qu'une fois que vous avez pu faire
preuve de concept par vous même sans
argent que vous pouvez en avoir
voilà
la troisième caractéristique c'est que
essayer de poursuivre votre grande idée
avoue il ya beaucoup de gens là on me
demande souvent est ce que vous n'êtes
pas peur des loueurs de voitures
traditionnelles et vous n'avez pas peur
de concurrents qui rentre et c'est en
fait on n'en a pas peur et réfléchissez
aussi à au combien de gens qui vous
disent autour de vous non moi je parle
pas de mon idée que la garde pour moi
j'ai peur que quelques mots la voix que
quelqu'un la copie si c'est le cas c'est
quelque part vous copier votre idée
simplement l'écoutant c'est que ce n'est
pas votre grande idée on savait que
personne ne pouvait réaliser ce projet
là à ce moment là à cet endroit là de
cette façon là parce qu'on avait les
compétences spécifiques pour les faire
parce qu'on avait la connaissance
spécifique pour le faire parce qu'on
avait le réseau spécifique pour le faire
et tout ça convergeaient sur le fait que
c'était notre grande idéal et beaucoup
de gens poursuivent et perdre du temps à
poursuivre la grande idée de quelqu'un
d'autre
et ça aussi c'est c'est un élément
important à prendre en compte lorsqu'on
a une grande idée et qu'on veut
l'évaluer savoir si on va y consacrer
une partie du reste de sa vie
la quatrième caractéristique commune des
grandes idées c'est ça les idées les
plus simples et les plus élégantes sont
toujours celles qui gagnent et là je
vais parler de la force du design les
entreprises qui ont le design au coeur
de leur stratégie
par exemple à la bourse de new york sont
six à sept fois plus performante que les
autres entreprises
et là je parle pas de faire du beau jeu
parle pas de faire du joli mais faire du
design c'est avoir de l'empathie avec
son utilisateur avoir de l'empathie avec
ses clients et l'appareil sont nés
presque vulgaire c'en est presque banal
et bateaux mais réfléchissez à votre
journée prenez une journée dans votre
semaine et réfléchissez à tout et aux
interactions que vous avez eue avec des
sociétés réelles réfléchissaient à
toutes les actions que vous avez eue
avec des institutions avec des marques
et réfléchissez aux à tous ces moments
où vous ne vous êtes pas senti pris en
compte
on nous a demandé de remplir un papier
que vous aviez déjà rempli
vous demander de remplir un formulaire
qui était incompréhensible à comprendre
tout ça c'est le design et tout ça fait
en prenant compte ça en prenant compte
l'empathie avec son utilisateur en
prenant comme son besoin sa douleur et
comment ils fonctionnent ces
caractéristiques propres
vous êtes en capacité de pouvoir faire
émerger de pouvoir faire aller loin une
grande idée
la dernière caractéristique commune des
grandes idées qui est peut-être la plus
importante c'est qu'elle réponde 1
pourquoi qu'elle réponde à une mission
qui est plus grande que nous qu'elles
vont au delà de nous mêmes tout à
l'heure vous allez en temps vous allez
entendre françois vous parler et je vais
pas vous parler je vais pas faire de
spoiler je vais lui laisser parler mais
sa grande mission c'est de d'éradiquer
le racisme sur la surface de la terre
quel que soit ce qu'il fait quelles que
soient les hésitations qu'il a dans son
projet les chemins détournés qu'il prend
on a envie de l'accompagner dans cette
mission on envie qu'ils réussissent on a
envie d'être avec lui on a envie de le
pousser parce que sa mission est plus
grande et on se rejoint sur cette
mission lorsqu'on a démarré c'est le
concept de location de voitures entre
particuliers
la vision était celle là elle était de
dire le tourisme ne reverse pas assez
aux populations locales
le tourisme un problème l'industrie
touristique ne rapporte pas aux
populations et qu'on peut qu'on ait une
solution qui leur permet de gagner plus
en plus d'être plus efficiente
écologiquement parlant qui leur permet
de vivre mieux
on a des gens qui utilisent notre
service et qu'ils nous disent grâce à ça
je peux aider mes enfants qui font leurs
études en métropole j'ai pu me payer des
vacances je peux aider ma famille je
peux vivre mieux je peux vivre plus et
c'est cette mission là qu'on a défini au
coeur de notre projet d'entreprise dès
le début qui a fait que aussi on a pu
convaincre les gens autour de nous de
nous rejoindre de nous poursuivre
d'aller plus loin de poursuivre c'est ce
projet ta grande idée le plus loin
possible
donc voilà c'est sa caractéristique qui
sont communes et comme vous allez
pouvoir retrouver dans toutes les
grandes idées 7 faire le test sur apple
sur le beurre / airbnb sur toutes ces
entreprises et grandes entreprises qui
sont des grandes idées vous allez
retrouver ses caractéristiques communes
est ce que j'ai envie ce soir c'est que
la prochaine fois mais que vous voyez
votre grande idée mais vous n'allez
s'est pas passé vous la reconnaissez et
puis vous y aller à fond
voilà
mais
d
le